this is footage from a hit lip session a
couple days ago well but a week ago it
went a lot better than expected
this was six fifty five four three after
six oh five four six which we're both
ers which kind of surprised me as you
can see I'm itching the first and second
reps a little bit just get impatient at
La Calvin I know I can get it without
itching so figure I'll just go ahead and
get the weight on up and that was 705
that was twenty pounds off my all-time
VR I was very happy with that when I did
725 I was totally fresh so I was happy
to get 705 after a little volume work
this is from last night now I'm starting
to use a polarized training model I'm
gonna write about that in my blog coming
up soon but I think it's something that
will agree with kind of my training
preferences it's a it's pretty much all
heavy all the time
this was horrified four three on the
bench it's been a while since I finished
heavy so as you can see I forgot how to
lower rep three and had to starts to
read back over but still got it
this was 275 or a drop back to set I'm
pausing with the bar got an inch off on
my chest
ahead of my dead point and so I'm just
kind of trying to train my body
be able to control them and manage a
press through that range of motion that
are also as you can see my my legs quite
pale so now on the squatting this was
for ninety five only the second time
I've had a heavy bar on my back in about
the past two months so as you'll see the
the weight moves pretty good but just
felt heavy on my back because I'm not
used to it anymore
that will come back pretty soon
this is 545 you I did this one actually
felt lighter on my back than 495 it I
think I think I was just kind of getting
used to the whole idea of squatting
again I mean since I've done a lot of
squats in my life my body figures out
what to do again pretty quickly again
that one was pretty easy went to 585 if
it felt really good I was gonna try to
get it for maybe like four or five reps
if it only felt kind of good I was
planning on policy in the second one but
it's just been a while so this this felt
like a load you saw me talking right
there that was to my wife she she was
criticizing my walk out on the 545 so I
was checking to make sure that one
looked better come on right here I'm
deciding that I'm not pausing the second
one so letting my spotter know that and
that's not all right thanks for watching
guys
you